bueno el presidente piñera para que la
gente lo comprenda es una persona que
lleva cerca de 30 años en donde más o
menos cada tres cuatro o cinco años se
le acusa de algún delito o de alguna
situación que está al borde de la
ilegalidad con respecto a sus negocios
recordemos para los que no lo saben que
el presidente piñera además de ser
presidente de la república es el segundo
tercer hombre más rico del país con
acciones en todos los rubros en esta
ocasión de lo que se le acusa muy
específicamente es que antes de su
primer período como como gobernante él
vendió sus intereses en una mina de
hierro en un sector que es de un
ecosistema muy delicado donde hay muchas
especies que solo se encuentran en ese
lugar y que la existencia de esa de esa
mina que se llama minera dominga hubiese
destruido el ecosistema él vendió sus
acciones a uno de sus mejores amigos
socio e imputado y condenado en otras
causas por corrupción
pero lo que se descubrió ahora y que no
se sabía era que estableció una tercera
cláusula un tercer pago de la venta de
esta mina en donde decía que el tercer
pago sólo se verificaba en caso de que
el gobierno no decretará zona de reserva
la zona en donde iba la mina haciendo
imposible que este proyecto funcionaria
es decir
vendió o estableció por contrato con un
precio determinado en dinero una
decisión que correspondía al presidente
de la república es decir el mismo es
decir hizo un contrato en un paraíso
fiscal de la isla virgen hábitat nica en
donde se establece que con una decisión
que depende de él él podría directamente
ganar dinero señor winter y es el
segundo juicio político que enfrenta el
sebastián piñera desde que ejerce el
mandato en chile y ya su mandato también
está por acabar el próximo año que tan
efectivo cree usted que puede ser este
juicio político en este contexto
es que eso tiene eso tiene dos dos
formas de verse yo creo que estoy la
cámara de diputados se va a probar pero
en el senado necesita dos tercios de los
votos
obviamente puede ser muy difícil de
conseguir dependiendo de los
antecedentes que se vayan verificando y
de la forma en que los senadores nos
aprecien y con respecto a las elecciones
quiero ser muy claro que no es no es
grato acusar al presidente la república
a mí no me gusta que se les presente la
república me gusta la idea de que los
presentes república terminan su mandato
nunca en nuestros 200 años de historia
republicana se ha destituido legalmente
sin embargo el nivel de rabia que hay en
la sociedad chilena por la sensación de
impunidad frente a un grupo de
empresarios que ha controlado la
totalidad de las decisiones económicas y
políticas del país durante más de tres
décadas es tan grande que mi impresión
es que independiente de que para las
elecciones presidenciales a mi sector no
le conviene esta acusación porque en mi
sector en el que según la encuesta va
ganando las elecciones creo que para la
estabilidad del país y para recomponer
la elección del pueblo con las
instituciones es necesario que se haga
justicia señor winter y usted estaba
hablando de un grupo económico podría
hablarnos un poco más al respecto y más
allá del del presidente sebastián piñera
si alguien más está mencionado en chile
en los papeles de pandora
si hay hay hay varios personajes pero
pero es importante relevar que en este
caso de la venta de esta minera
en donde se involucran además evasión
tributaria cierto y negociación
incompatible tráfico influencia y
también destrucción del medio ambiente
el comprador y éste un dato bien
relevante el comprador que aparece
mencionado es decir el que le iba a
pagar al presidente si es que lograba
evitar que la institucionalidad
medioambiental funcionara es una persona
que fue protagonista de los casos
corrupción es más grandes que hemos
tenido en nuestra historia que era el
caso en el que un banco el banco penta
del cual esta persona es dueño se llama
carlos alberto délano había estado
durante 20 años financiando las campañas
de los políticos a través de boletas y
que lógicamente falsa por servicios que
no se prestaban realmente generando un
fraude al fisco que duró 20 años y
alcanzó millones entonces personas tuvo
en la cárcel